nous savons tous qu'une des causes
majeures du dysfonctionnement de la
chaîne pénale qui trop souvent installe
une forme d'impunité réside dans
l'insuffisance de capacité carcérale
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont
malheureusement
particulièrement préoccupant 122% de
taux d'occupation dans nos prisons
presque 150% dans les maisons d'arrêt
qu'est-ce que cela signifie d'abord nous
avons des prisons qui se trouvent dans
une situation indigne avec 2200 matelas
au sol qui installe une forme
d'inhumanité aujourd'hui il faut
réhabiliter la forme de la sanction
dissuasive et la prison doit être doit
être aujourd'hui et souvent le seul
moyen pour dissuader la commission d'un
crime ou d'un délit donc il faut revenir
vers des taux d'incarcération qui soit
plus élevé et il y a pas il n'y a pas de
multiples solutions la seule solution
c'est de construire plus de place de
prison il faut changer de braquer
monsieur le ministre il faut aller plus
loin vous le fait d'entre votre loi
d'orientation plus 15000 places nous
vous proposons nous vous demandons
d'aller plus loin en rajoutant 3000
places supplémentaires la phase la plus
difficile lorsque l'on construit des
prisons
et par expérience celle de la recherche
foncière et des contentieux
administratifs qui ont découle ça prend
entre deux et trois ans vous avez
compris le principe la prison oui mais
ailleurs dans la commune d'à côté dans
la circo d'à côté c'est vrai pour moi
c'est vrai pour tous les garde des
sceaux qui ont envisagé la construction
de place de prison c'est pourquoi moi je
lance un appel
solennel républicain afin que localement
cesse les tentatives d'entravent direct
joint direct des constructions de place
de prison
j'assume la construction de place de
prison pour la fermeté de la réponse
pénale mais également pour les
conditions dignes et pour les conditions
de travail des personnels pénitentiaires
auxquels naturellement nous pensons tous
les chèques est rude pour ceux qui ont
cherché les voies de l'efficacité
pendant des heures ici et qui au final
découvrent dans ce projet l'idée rabattu
de toujours plus de place de prison 3000
places donc en toute logique puisqu'on
est dans une loi de programmation c'est
avant 2025 madame Hunter a la parole
c'est un amendement à plus d'un milliard
d'euros qui divisent par moitié
l'augmentation historique du budget de
la justice de 2 milliards en 2027